is one of the greatest actors television
has ever known from one of the greatest
shows televisions ever given us
please welcome Bryan Cranston you're the
king
while they thought my blue [ __ ] was good
Brian France yeah that's a real act
that's amazing
you know I am huh you know exactly who I
am
I'm not JD Harmar
on our
come on
ah say my name
so it was Walt Eisen brianstone burg
Brian [ __ ] Cranston yeah
I'm the man who won three goddamn Emmys
a Golden Globe handful of SAG Awards and
in the 80s I was nominated for a cable
ace award yeah very proud of that lay it
out there seven people knew with that
was I know some of you think that I am
the danger I am NOT the danger the real
danger is Howard Stern my credulous went
up he is the one who knocks I mean have
you ever hear me we've all heard him
yelling Gary that's some scary [ __ ]
right there
all right Howard I just want to say
thank you for inviting me to your bash I
adore you
you are absolutely phenomenal you're on
my radio every morning thank you for
being here I'm honored thank you very
much Robin I love you you look
Gemini I love you you look beautiful who
do you love more B or Jimmy
usually you look beautiful beautiful
both of Diplomat out our next guess is
is not so scary in fact he's not scary
at all he would make Tom Hanks look like
Hitler ladies and gentlemen the new host
of The Tonight Show with Jay Leno sorry
Jimmy Jimmy